[Music]  I'm sick and tired of people telling me  that America is the greatest country  because we can whip your ass I hate some  of these people but I've never come  how do you deal with this you're never  gonna be able to unsee what you saw  try to impeach you just try and you will  have a spasm of violence in this country  like you'd ever seen  governor Snyder I got some point water  for you  [Music]  if nobody's gonna do it then I gotta do  it and I will give you you are I'll  fight you in the damn street right now  okay how did this happen the American  dream  is dead stop resisting  the President's powers here are beyond  question ladies and gentlemen the last  President of the United States  [Music]  coming to an American city near you  you